I want to of course start by welcoming
our very distinguished panelists and
welcome each one of you for taking the
time to be here we really believe this
is a landmark event and what that needed
to come with the urgency that it did my
name is Angela Kapoor Goethe and I'm a
faculty member at the y el child study
center I'm currently working on the area
of early childhood development in a
global setting and I'm one of the many
people across campus that has come
together to put this event today when we
started thinking about this event only
maybe three weeks ago or so we were very
worried that we wouldn't have enough
time to put an event of this caliber
together but in all honesty within hours
of getting the word out we had support
from all across campus and outside of
Yale as well and I think this speaks
volumes about our community about our
power about our strengths and about the
ability to mobilize when it is most
needed I'm literally going to take one
minute of today's panel to sort of set
the stage of why we're here in what
we're seeking to accomplish and why we
need really everybody that is hearing us
today and that's here with us either
through the recording that's going to be
released later on or physically here
with us today I think and the panelists
I'm sure we'll talk about this that we
are living in a historic moment you know
NHC r has released many statistics that
are alarming but one of them that has
come out recently is that as of the year
2014 about 59 million people were
displaced 51-percent of those are
children just letting that sink in for a
minute I'm not sure there's a right word
for it may be daunting is the only word
to think about this but again we have
hope and we believe in our Yale
community and we truly believe that by
informing ourselves and thinking
seriously about action
we will be able we hope to make
sustained difference this is going to be
a process and we by no means pretend
that this is going to bring immediate
answers so really the outcome of this we
hope of today's event is that we will be
able to generate hopefully a set of
recommendations that of course are going
to have to go through the appropriate
channels at Yale but it is really going
to inform joint action across campus and
we know that there are other initiatives
out there our focus today is in the
young children and the families that
have been struck by the war and the
crisis recently in the middle east and
north africa region your engagement of
course should not end here again this is
the beginning of a process you will see
that there will be some lists that are
or some requests for your email we
really really ask you to please give us
your contact information because we hope
that this will be the first of other
events and that this is going to provide
sustained communication so make sure
that you do that before you leave today
and I just want to close by saying that
amongst many efforts at Yale our group
at the Yale Child Study Center led in
part by dr. John Wegman and dr. a masala
and others have been very engaged in a
global strategy of global initiative to
shift the paradigm of peace building and
really think about investing in early
childhood development as a mechanism for
sustained peace we believe that in the
young children truly the evidence says
that policy says experiences that that
is where peace lies and sustainable
peace lies we're very actively engaged
through an emerging an emerging early
childhood peace consortium that partners
such as a chef and UNICEF are supporting
and we would like to keep you informed
of those important efforts so by you
providing us with your information we
will be able to make you a part of that
as well so please be sure to do that
again and then I'm just going to pass it
on to my colleague Kyle but of course
not before thinking enjoyed Joseph's and
others at the mechelen Center and again
across campus that have made this event
possible so we really want to thank them
for their sponsorship and their support
and dr. Kyle Pruitt is going to
take it on Thank You Angie good
afternoon we are here to learn and to be
simulated by a rather remarkable group
of distinguished thinkers movers and
shakers some of you may be wondering why
we are focusing on the early years when
there is so much that needs to be done
with the later years our belief that
children start off well and we need to
be putting our efforts into keeping them
well because if we don't then the world
really is going to be losing hope very
quickly and this group of thinkers has
been devoted to that many of them for
most of their lives you'll hear from
each of them I want to introduce them to
you individually first of all I like
Excel who is the CEO of mother and child
foundation in Turkey and of the whose
nose egan foundation their work as an
NGO has been distinguished in European
countries of the Middle East as well
affecting 10,000 teachers in ways that
have changed their lives Christopher
George executive director of the
integrated refugee and immigrant
services here in new haven former Peace
Corps member was Save the Children was
the officer in Gaza for a number of
years and has been a been involved in
Middle East for 25 years katie murphy
early childhood development technical
advisor at the International Rescue
Committee a born in New Haven and also
was deputy director of the Columbia
Earth Institute before coming to the
International Rescue Committee as their
early childhood advisor Nicholas of dr.
Nicholas Ali Bowie who is UNICEF's
director of program and director of
senior advisor in the post 2015
government agenda he is from Ghana he is
an obstetrician and gynecologist
and has with a special interest in
amplifying the boy the voices of boys
and girls dr. Mooney karuna Cara former
international president of medicines
fonte'yah Doctors Without Borders and is
a native of India senior fellow at the
Jackson Institute for Global Alliance at
Yale which is part of the melon Center
where we sit today I'm going to begin by
asking them each a question they will
then spend a few minutes ads answering
those questions as related to their own
individual institutions and then we will
ask them as another's and you will ask a
second question I will ask a third after
they are done talking about their
answers to these questions we will then
open the microphones to the audience for
questions because we are fast we are
very interested in how this information
strikes you and how it mobilizes you to
make use of what they are urging us to
do here in the Yale community the first
question I'll begin with with with ila
describe the ways in which your agency
is currently adjusting its programming
to address the displacement crisis in
the Middle East and the North Africa
region with particular emphasis on young
children and families thank you very
much it's a pleasure and honor to be
here I'm just going to give you some
very quick facts about the situation of
refugees in Turkey some of you may know
some of you may not but it'll just give
you a context of the enormity of the
problem that we're talking about Turkey
as many of you know has been one of the
countries have been most affected by the
refugee crisis we currently have two
million registered refugees then I
actually called refugees they're called
guests and we have another estimated
quarter of a million that are
unregistered over half of them are under
18 and around twenty percent are under
11 and only around 220,000 are actually
in the camps so that's a whole lot of
people that are dispersed all across the
country where it's very difficult to get
comprehensive programming to
Turkey's spent around six billion
dollars on refugees in the past for four
years so that's enormous and only
they've only received about 400 million
from international sources um the
government has been very I think quite
successful in providing basic health
care and especially in the camps but
education has really been the biggest
challenge at the moment seventy percent
of the children of school age are not in
school now what does this mean it means
that without the chance of education as
one government official put it these
children run the risk of falling to
radical groups which is part of the
problem that we're already facing but
more so education is actually needed for
the bigger question that we're now
facing which is one about inclusion
integration because I don't know if any
of you have seen that the very recent
report from the Brookings Institute that
came out last week on Syrians in Turkey
but the title of the report is actually
called not likely to go home so today
the conversation really needs to be
about how we're going to integrate
include these refugees into the
communities and societies in which they
are currently in they may go back in a
year's time they may go back in five
years time we don't know I don't think
anyone knows but our response today has
to be to provide them with the best
opportunities to set the foundation of
life and that really means for for the
earliest years just a couple more
sentences on what we're doing
unfortunately we're not doing a lot the
reason why we're not doing a lot is that
up until very very recently the
government of Turkey didn't really
embrace or include NGOs I think this was
probably the
the initial strategy was that you know
we have an open-door policy and we've
got this you know it's okay it's
probably only going to be a quarter of a
million you know that three years ago
the government had said that their cat
for them the like their red line was a
hundred thousand that was going to be
their red line today we're talking about
two million so when it's 100,000 you can
think okay we've got this we you know we
don't really need to get all kinds of
agencies involved but you know as the
problem has become much more severe and
it's really only be in the past few
months that they've started to open up
and look at what can be done for more
comprehensive programming both with
international NGOs and and local NGOs so
this is a question that we're deliberate
at the moment I think for local NGOs one
of the problems one of the challenges is
how do you ensure that you remain within
your mission especially during a local
NGO that are serving local populations
how do you merge that with your
constituency to suddenly turn around and
say okay I'm actually going to start
serving Syrians and later on in the in
the discussion I think we're going to be
talking about challenges and I'll I'll
address that there so I'll stop there
thank you very much thank you thanks for
convening this group it is a very
important topic senator Blumenthal held
press conference this morning and
Hartford talking about the overseas
stages of the refugee resettlement
process our work begins when refugees
arrived here in many of you are probably
thinking well the ones who come here
they're the lucky ones compared to those
who are living in refugee camps or other
areas in Turkey and Lebanon and Jordan
so in some respects they are but we
can't just drop the ball on the needs of
children who come through the refugee
resettlement program 70,000 refugees
over the past three years every year
have been invited by the US government
to come the United States iris is one of
about 350 refugee resettlement agencies
spread across the country 350 a network
of well supported nonprofit org
which is why we say to the government
you can take more than an additional
fifteen thousand refugees the crisis is
huge our response needs to be bigger so
we're pushing for numbers more in the
area of 200,000 refugees and not just
85,000 which is what the Department of
State has mentioned you speak to refugee
parents who've arrived in this country
and they say you know I might have been
able to eke out a decent living in
Jordan or Lebanon or maybe in Turkey if
I'd been alone but I've got kids and
I've come to this country for their
future that puts responsibility on
refugee resettlement agencies not just
to do the basics and all of us spend
most of our time doing the basics
housing food employment teaching English
connecting to health care most of us
treat early childhood education programs
and education programs in general for
Refugees as kind of a an extra a luxury
it needs to be an essential service and
iris has tried to raise sufficient
private funds and use amazing volunteers
from Yale and other universities and
places around the state in order to
mount an education program for the
children we have a childhood pro early
childhood education program at our
office but just for six kids there's a
waiting list of more than twenty we have
an after-school program for refugee kids
we have a summer school program we have
in school two turds and all this is run
by an education coordinator to address
the special needs of refugee kids how
much more time do I have
a minute what are those needs let me
just quickly race through them maybe we
can talk more about them in detail one
of the greatest needs is communication
most refugees arrive here they don't
speak English kids are admitted into the
school system as English language
learners the refugee resettlement
program that sponsors refugees needs to
have someone who can arrange to find
interpreters for the kids we can't just
leave it up to the school districts
children learn English faster than their
parents so that often pushes them into
roles and responsibilities in their
family I see a lot of people nodding
their head maybe they themselves were in
a similar position but I mentioned this
to a group of older students and woman
sitting next to me started to cry as I
described how kids are pushed into roles
of much greater responsibility than
their years would would would suggest as
interpreters as navigators through the
culture so unique we need to provide
interpreters not just for kids in the
school system but also for their family
so that they don't depend just on their
children there are feelings of isolation
not surprisingly on the part of refugee
students in the school system we need to
have programs that will organize refugee
students into safe and nurturing
welcoming groups by themselves and then
also mainstream mainstream them into the
larger population whenever possible we
try to minimize change put them in a
school and not bounce them six months
later into another school although
sometimes this need to keep a sense of
stability with refugee students
sometimes that might run counter to the
other objective of finding the best
educational opportunities moving to a
magnet school for example we've noticed
a lot of our parent
are very resistant to moving their kids
from the first school where they were
placed to a magnet school even though it
might be offering a better education all
this points to the need for refugee
resettlement agencies to have education
coordinators on staff at least part-time
to work with the school system primarily
to help the students also the families
and then to ensure that refugee
resettlement this great tradition that
we're all so supportive of that refugee
resettlement is welcomed in the
community and not seen as a burden thank
you well thank you to the organizers
into the Yale community for bringing
this important topic to the forefront
and it's really an honor to be part of
this panel so the International Rescue
Committee provides a unique perspective
on the refugee experience and that we
serve the entire continuum of the
trajectory of the refugee life side
cycle so beginning with our programs in
Syria where over half of the population
has been forced to flee their home 7.5
million are internally displaced living
within Syria and the rest of them have
been able to flee to neighboring
countries within Syria we have 13
refugee camps or providing educational
services as well as parenting programs
the parenting programs because of the
traumatic experiences that caregivers
have faced in the chaos of displacement
are really focused on psychosocial
support and dealing with their own
trauma and experiences that they can
provide nurturing care for their
children and help them to build
resilience in their children in the
neighbouring countries of Jordan Turkey
Lebanon and Iraq we have programs that
have served longer term populations of
Syrian refugees along with refugees from
other neighboring countries and these
range also from education programs to
parenting programs we have a strong
child protection system which often
focus focus as much of a
efforts on family reunification and
tracing so during the process of
relocating or forced displacement from
one country to the next families are
often separated and so ensuring that
those children find their caregivers or
if not available appropriate foster care
is a huge priority we have emergency
operations in the island of Lesbos
Greece where over half of the immigrants
who are arriving from by boat to Europe
are arriving each day and numbers that
range from four to six thousand per day
in an island that originally was about
60 to 70 thousand population the
challenges that we face there are
enormous because this is more of a
transit zone so we're ensuring that we
can screen for basic safety and
protection measures but also this is not
a place where we're doing long-term
programming such as education and
parenting programs but ensuring that
there's critical support provided for
that process and that they have access
to legal rights and information that's
so needed in a time that can be so
distressing and confusing and then we
have programs in the US across 26 cities
where we work similar to Iris and
resettlement programs in an effort for
community reintegration so across this
whole spectrum of experience there's a
variety of various different challenges
and ways that we need to think
differently about serving the needs of
young children and families which we can
talk more in the discussion Thanks thank
you very much I think in the United in
the United Nations there is a
well-established system of dealing with
refugee crisis and this goes back many
many years there is an interagency
Standing Committee that brings together
an operational UN agencies
nongovernmental
positions and the Red Cross for
coordination purposes so which one knows
what the other was doing the UN has its
refugee agency united nations high
commissioner for refugees which has the
Mandate of doing nothing other than just
focusing on providing shelter protection
and believe with asylum seekers unicef's
comparative advantage is the fact that
the organization is present in all
countries as a universal presence which
makes a huge difference being on the
ground and being able to firsthand
conduct situation analysis and
assessments to determine the priorities
of children particularly the youngest
ones in situations of displacement and
refugee crisis UNICEF has been
particularly concerned over the last 23
years with the impact of both climate
change drought in Syria and the war
there on children and the displacement
of massiveness basement that you just
heard about and has been tireless
working to avoid what we are calling a
no-loss generation and in which is to
ensure that without presence in the
originating country in transit countries
as well as in recipient countries we are
able to provide critical life-saving
services and support to children and
their families so the no load generation
campaign or initiative status in three
years ago was meant essentially to
ensure that refugee children displaced
within Syria and within countries such
as their those new movies or elsewhere
or those that have cross borders and
happy
at active asylum seekers are able to
access education all forms including
early childhood education with teacher
training and psychosocial support and
secondly to provide protection for these
children and this is done through a
series of mechanisms for example our
most recent assessments are being turned
best interest assessments where
essentially the best interest of the
child is the organizing framework around
which determinations that made as to
whether or not to place the children at
home in a van or in a particular
situation or otherwise best interest
determinations require the involvement
of government officials and public
officials in relief and this would mean
where decisions are made on the type of
support that type of family support and
Asylum that is then provided for the
needy needy family unit the third aspect
of this is training of local communities
and leaders who provide the leadership
on the ground in a sustainable way one
would need to ensure that local leaders
particularly women's groups youth
organizations themselves are also
involved in the process of resettlement
and support to refugee children lastly
what we have been really engaged in is
negotiating access for for these
boundaries this is a lot of
behind-the-scenes heavy lifting advocacy
work and speaking to non-state actors
and government in some situations to
permit free access for children to move
freely
across the landscape in addition to all
of this our normal regular health
nutrition water and sanitation programs
are provided in the camps and in IDP
internally displaced persons camps and
along the route where children travel to
their homes of asylum thank you before
we focus on Middle East on a start a
little bit further east on Saturday from
20 8 a.m. until 3 15 am time in in
Afghanistan MSF's hospital in Kunduz was
hit by a series of the aerial bombing
raids at approximately 15 minute
intervals so the main central hospital
building housing the 10 sec a unit
emergency rooms and the physiotherapy
ward was repeatedly hit very precisely
during each aerial rate with white
surrounding buildings were left mostly
untouched 12 staff members 12m surface
and 10 patients including three children
were killed 37 people were injured
including 19 host enemies I hope you
will all support NSF in our call for an
independent investigation of what
clearly constitutes a violation grave
violation of international humanitarian
law now i start in afghanistan to make a
point this is also going on in Syria
more than seventy percent of all health
facilities have been destroyed the
Syrian government has had a deliberate
policy to attack health facilities
attack health personnel and to
in a very fundamental way prevent people
from receiving the life-saving care they
need today in Syria you have roughly
three zones of control one-third of the
country is controlled by Assad and it's
controlled by the government once third
is controlled by the Free Syrian Molly
or so anti-assad opposition supported by
the u.s. supported by European
governments and also Arab countries such
as Saudi Arabia Qatar United Arab
Emirates etc and then of course the
third part is controlled by what we call
dice or Isis and there of course
supported by our so-called allies Saudi
Arabia Qatar Kuwait United Arab Emirates
oh it's a bit and then of course there's
Russia and Iran and you know a few other
countries in the mix so it's all a bit
of a so you're talking about lives of
people in this in this scenario as Katie
said earlier and as you said earlier I
mean more than half people more than
half the population has been displaced I
think two days ago report was released
off the 250,000 people who've been
killed reportedly killed in Syria in the
last five years 26.5 percent have been
children the mortalities right so these
are people in Syria now the lucky ones
who are able to get out out of the 12
million displaced I think about five
million and being able to five million
plus have been able to get out of the
country and they live in various states
if you know they'll receive various
states of assist various levels of
assistance in Turkey you said seventy
percent of the students were out of
school
children model that's eighty percent in
Lebanon today Lebanon one out of every
four person in Lebanon is a refugee
right and the school system is just not
able to cope the Lebanese government has
has sort of committed to providing
education for 200,000 students but
that's just a small proportion of the
children that need to be in school what
do we do MSF Doctors Without Borders we
have various levels of access we have
absolutely no permission or access to
work in a soft control areas we have
repeatedly requested the government to
allow and allow us them to provide
assistance and we've always been denied
access of course we work with the large
network of Syrian doctors and health
professionals to provide services inside
the country we have to keep in mind
today most of the humanitarian
assistance provided in Syria is provided
by Syrian groups Syrian doctors Syrian
and nurses Syrian healthcare
professionals who take incredible amount
of risks to clandestine operations
bringing in drugs bringing in medical
materials to take care of their own
citizens incredible pneus thousands of
healthcare workers have been killed in
in the past five years all of this to
say that what used to be a reasonably
good health system has come from bold
and it's completely fallen apart
children are not being vaccinated so a
lot of vaccine preventable illnesses
you're seeing a rice in the numbers of
vaccine product preventable illnesses if
they come out you know turkey is trying
to do its best it's only recently in the
last couple of months that they have
loud
ngos to start providing services in
turkey so hopefully because turkey can't
cope with the influx of refugees in the
country so now they've allowed NGOs to
start providing services so now you can
perhaps see a little bit more or care
being provided Lebanon has been
stretched to its limit it's it's big you
know it's a big miracle for me that they
haven't been caught in the Syrian
conflict I I had given them one year
before Lebanon would be part of the
Syrian conflict but somehow they've
managed to stay out of it here of course
Lebanon does not get the kind of
assistance that international assistance
that turkey gets the jordan gets partly
because let the government of Lebanon is
considered to be affiliated with the
Hezbollah so no one wants to give them
money but they've managed I think
reasonably well there's a lot of funds
from the UN you etc which sort of helps
Jordan of course the numbers are much
lower don't also forget that many of the
refugees are in Iraq more than half a
million refugees are Syrian refugees are
in Iraq and this is going from one boy
brought to another boiling pot just one
more I just want to complete this sorry
then of course you shouldn't forget to
all the people coming to Europe but
remember refugee flows to Europe only a
small percentage actually it's largely
adult males but that doesn't mean that
the children who come have have needs i
mean we've been rescuing people from we
have three boats in the mediterranean
all summer you know picking people up
from boats that are about to capsize
with children etc so the entire entire
journey from conflict to a place where
they find refuge is fraught with danger
and every step of the way there
is incredibly modest assistance and
service that meets that we provided for
children but not just children sorry
thank you onion everybody for this
incredibly important contributions and
this next question is probably at this
point a little bit of more of a recap
you've touched on this just a little but
we really want to you make a really good
point I mean this is a crisis across the
lifespan again today we have to make a
decision to focus on on children and we
we really want to think about now
challenges in this area in particular
and we want to hear from you all other
recapping or new information and what
are the greatest challenges in reaching
the most vulnerable children and
providing not only their safety but as
well as access to services that and
environments that promote and protect
their healthy development and if you've
already sort of touched on that maybe
you can tell us how are your
organization's trying to overcome these
challenges we think that this will be
very important to inform our own process
I mean very quickly we have already
talked about it but there's one aspect
that I haven't talked about we talked
about education a lot but the child is
not doesn't live in a vacuum doesn't
grow up in a vacuum it has a family and
that family needs to subsist and for
that to happen that family needs
employment so that is the biggest
challenge facing turkey at the moment we
have to provide education and we have to
provide some form of legal employment
although the government of Turkey came
out again about a year ago saying they
would provide a would enable the
refugees are the guests to seek
employment and to be gainfully employed
just before the elections this was sort
of retracted by the Ministry of Labour
because it's obviously causing tensions
among the local populations but this is
something that needs to be addressed
because i'm not talking about what's
happening in Syria that's an altogether
different situation or what happened
in Europe or in America because again
that's a different situation they're
here they reset that on the part of
resettlement in Turkey it's very much
still a transition process but we have
only just got to the point where saying
this is not a trend we have to start
thinking about long-term development and
longer-term integration so in terms of
challenges education employment
strengthening turkeys reception and
integration system and also managing
this whole risk of xenophobia this is a
huge challenge when you have 2.2 2.3
million people you know in some
provinces the refugee populations
exceeded local population that can you
imagine what this does the fabric of a
community and you have to manage that
risk of of xenophobia um and I think
that we need to coordinate better this
whole global humanitarian response and
this notion of burden sharing yes
Lebanon Jordan Turkey have all been very
generous ah but you know the generosity
has has limits just purely you know
financial limits there's I don't think
that turkey can spend another six
billion i don't think that Lebanon and
Jordan will be able to spend how much
they have so the burden sharon has to
happen and it has to happen very very
quickly and we need more comprehensive
programming one point on young children
I mean I think we've talked a touch
little bit about upon how it's important
to focus on the young children basic
focus on young children and their
families this is what I think is most
important because there is this
obviously a huge sensitivity but if you
can build up resilience in the family
and whether when they're going through
this fragile state then they will be
better prepared for whatever they will
face in the future whether it's stayin
in that country where it's going to
Europe or it's going back to their own
country that
we've seen that working with families
with children in their most formative
years can really make difference
unfortunately despite all the best
intentions of both the local NGOs and
the international NGOs that i've been
working at least i can only speak to
turkey I don't know so much about the
other countries it's actually not
reaching that many people I mean in
terms I know of the the local NGOs that
work in there each in like maybe a few
hundred there a few hundred there it's
not anywhere near the scale that it
needs to be at and similarly with the
international NGOs us as a speaker
before me said you know turkey was
actually closed off to international
NGOs up until quite recently so the the
pockets in which they are allowed to
operate were again quite quite small
they were certainly not out into in the
local communities where the majority of
the refugees are and it also means
madness my last sentence is that in many
communities now you have like parallel
communities because we haven't addressed
this issue of integration or inclusion
we are there were Syrian schools being
sprung up and nobody knew what these
schools were doing what they were
teaching is only like a few weeks or
months ago the Turkish Ministry of
Education said there are going to be no
illegal or informal schools operating
they're all going to be taken under the
ownership or administration of of the
Minister of Education which you know
again I think we need to think about
because do we want Syrian refugee
children necessarily going for the
Turkish education system do these
children not have the right especially
if they have a propensity to go back to
Syria to learn in their own language and
in their own curricula so they can be
much better prepared for the lives that
they wish to return to all four
or somewhere else oh there's there's all
kinds of of challenges I know I spoken
more about the broader challenges as
opposed to my own agencies challenges
but my own age six challenges I already
address saying that you know we weren't
really allowed into a space beyond very
simple humanitarian relief and we're not
in the business of humanitarian relief
as a ship we work in longer-term our
programming with children and families
so I'll stop there before I address the
question I just wanted to say that I've
come into contact with Doctors Without
Borders over the years around the world
throughout the Middle East and you will
not find a tougher more fearless more
creative more determined tenacious
organization in saving lives than MSF it
is horrible what happened in Kunduz I
just like to honor your work under the
most dangerous circumstances
it is important to look at the family
and families of refugees coming the
United States go through a lot their
parents are probably wondering why the
hell did we ever come here I can't learn
this language how am I going to find a
job how am I going to pay the rent will
my children respect me if I come home
and tell them my job is washing dishes
it is a stressful depressing for some
high anxiety experience that parents go
through and they're not always there to
support their children and some of that
stress is transferred to the kids the
kids have in some cases experienced some
horrible persecution and violence they
carry those scars with them they need
counseling when they get to this country
language is a huge obstacle we need the
resources refugee resettlement agencies
need the resources to make sure that
they get that care it's not always
recognized because they don't speak the
language parents their parents will
maybe be the last people to reach out
for help because they're still stigma
associated with mental health needs so
we need to train teachers and others who
are working with these kids to be extra
sensitive have their antenna up spot the
needs as they surface and get them the
care they need it's interesting the
transition to schools in the United
States is a difficult one for for
refugee kids most have had some formal
schooling but it's all been interrupted
almost by definition a refugee of
child's schooling has been interrupted
they'll often tell us that they're
appalled by the lack of discipline and
the lack of respect in American schools
the lack of respect for teachers I spoke
with an Iraqi who would
a teacher in Iraq and he said teachers
were practically next to God in terms of
respect here they're treated like dirt
that's an adjustment for kids the
challenge that we're facing now is how
to maintain community support keep the
focus on the needs of refugees and make
sure that the support continues my phone
has been ringing off the hook for the
past three weeks emails are streaming
and from all over Connecticut you know
from from Woodstock up in the Northeast
to Wilton every community wants to help
refugees how do we maintain that how do
we keep that level of support and public
attention hi that's one of our
challenges Thanks I think many of the
key challenges have been flagged by my
colleagues but just to reiterate also my
appreciation for msf and deep
condolences for that horrible tragedy
which does highlight one of the the
major challenges we have within the
Syrian region in that the indiscriminate
attacks against civilians the absolute
denial of the UN Security Council
resolution to ensure that there is safe
provision of humanitarian aid and
protection of civilians has completely
been in words only and there's been no
enforcement of this and so this has
deeply affected our own operations as
well as other organizations who are
working within Syria and is something
that deserves a lot of international
attention and pressure to ensure that
these types of security resolutions
actually have teeth and are enforced
rather than just in words so the the
challenge is very drastically by context
where we're working in Lebanon as only
mentioned a quarter of the a quarter to
a third of the population is projected
to be Syrian the government despite
their efforts have not been able to
absorb the
enormous influx of refugees and so
working to provide educational services
again parenting programs is very
difficult particularly in context where
they're not just living only in camps
often that's what you see in the news
but we work very closely also with
street children and as isla mentioned we
don't just look at the the situation of
the children but the drivers of what
brought them to the street and often
that is the lack of economic resources
for the caregivers who push their
children to beg or sell on the street
because it's actually more income than
they could generate themselves and so
providing livelihoods training trying to
secure employment for mothers and
families of small children to ensure
that they're not going out in the street
is one way that we're able to support
that the challenges that we face in the
context like Greece are very different
we see women who are arriving
breastfeeding their their children and
due to the trauma of displacement are
unable to provide are unable to
breastfeed their child anymore and so
they're suffering from nutritional
deficiencies but also need psychosocial
support to go along with the medical
intervention that needs to be provided
in that context so across the various
different situations we look we try to
address these challenges it's actually
pretty hard to pick out a few challenges
to speak to about the kind of traumatic
crisis that's unfolding out there it's
extremely complicated and complex and as
was just mentioned depending on context
whether you're dealing with challenges
within the country the originating
country or in countries in in transit
where the refugees transit or where they
are
as destination you face different
different types of challenges and in our
kids because we have this Universal
versus this challenge is manifest
themselves in different place what i
have done is categorized living for all
so easy to remember topics one is the
ability to continue to monitor the grave
violations of children's rights which is
the ability to collect data speak to
local organizations I speak to mothers
and children themselves on any forms of
abuse and grave violations particularly
that are happening within their life the
transit through various countries on the
way to destination so data collection
evidence base and the monitoring of
grave violations of children is one area
in which we find extremely we find it
extremely difficult to carry on
following a migrant population that's
moving from one place to the other
continuously were experiencing different
types of abuse the second is that of
course it's already known that UNICEF
has a world-recognized voice for
children and it's an authority on issues
related to children but this verse tends
to be drowned out when there are loud
abuses and there's loud open battles
going on you never quite sure how much
you can say or expose of the situation
of children without first putting more
people in jeopardy or in fact closing
access to the organization itself in
areas whether it's ongoing conflict so
even though the voice is there the use
of the voice to defend children I find
in my experience has become strained by
practical
reality and so at times I have a feeling
we are not speaking out loud enough and
at times when we speak out too loud the
bros clothes and outfits third capacity
when you when you're trekking along with
a moving population you don't always
have resident capacity and adequate
capacity to deal with the requirements
in terms of service provision as well as
protection of children and women as well
as the move especially in the area of
psychosocial support movement is
traumatic for children and for their
parents and it's extremely important not
to underestimate the psychosocial impact
of this type of situation on young
children these are experiences that they
carry with them their whole life and a
lot of children are shaped by these
experiences moving forward and at times
of trauma persists over years and it's
easy it's necessary to catch these
impacts early the problem is that there
isn't enough capacity given the numbers
that we are talking about a whole entire
half population of Syria's been this
place to provide the support not only to
children but also to the plants and
finally the issue of detention of
children whenever the family or the
child is arrested the ability to
negotiate alternatives to detention it's
fraught with all kinds of ethical
dilemmas if the parents are detained
would you rather have the child with
them in detention or separate from their
parents in a strange land and these
kinds of challenges but what it means is
that there is a need to work out an
alternative judicial
protection system for younger for young
children and the appearance in
situations of what is termed illegal
migration of when the asylum situation
fails um so let me leave it there for
now mmm just a couple minutes yes so the
biggest challenge that doctors without
borders faces in providing services for
children is access it just can't get to
the children who need care that much so
there are several reasons why we can't
get to the models of course conflict and
in conflict inside the country this
deliberate attack of healthcare workers
doctors itself seconds of registration
delays in in Lebanon and in other
countries because registration of people
coming across the border is what
entitles them to Memphis so the
registration delays it just happened a
lot in this in Lebanon and another part
is one big barrier to children receiving
the services they need second government
policies so we just heard about Turkey
and their policy towards you know
refugees that is changing slowly but
government policy is not just in Turkey
but also in European countries is
another big barrier to children
receiving assistance third is just lack
of respect for international conventions
that are being signed refugees have a
right to seek asylum yet all sorts of
barriers are being placed to prevent
refugees families and their children
from seeking asylum so that's another
big barrier why they will get care and
then of course you know the general
public center phobia we just don't want
people you know in our midst there are
people who do but by and large there is
a big backlash against and politicians
have also used language so
these are all reasons wherever we
provide weather wherever we are able to
reach the refugees and children we
provide neonatal care services so safe
safe delivery services vaccinations in
northern Syria and in other places we
vaccinate all children we tried to you
know the full epi vaccination schedule
for children under the age of three and
we have had specific measles vaccination
campaigns in several several places in
this context then another big need is
reconstructive surgery there are an
amazing number of children who have been
injured they have been burnt they've
lost Lynn and they need reconstructive
surgery and long-term post-operative
rehab services so this is something that
really was attention because the number
of kids who've been affected by conflict
not just mentally in difficulties and
the last of course as you said is mental
health which we also try and provide
counseling safe spaces you know all that
sort of stuff I think perhaps IRC does
more in that without them we do but
wherever possible we also provide mental
health services for refugee children
Thank You Lee we have time I think for
one question if you step to the mic
please hi good afternoon my name is
Megan I fell I'm a mental health and
education advocate here in New Haven and
I grew up at the United Nations in New
York 35 years of my mom most of what you
described here is what we are dealing
with here in New Haven at some level and
I've also come to other conferences here
with Middle Eastern women and it seems
that it's very difficult for us
even here in the US to tackle these
issues I could think of how many kids
that are not getting their vaccinations
have barriers because of their parents i
will be talking more to Chris after this
because I realize now Chris isn't at the
table where we working our restorative
justice practice and discipline policy
in schools so I think if we can work
within the u.s. at a more local level
kind of as not as an incubator or some
of these practices what works what
doesn't work you talked about you know
your voice being too loud you can have
doors closed not loud enough things
aren't done we go through this all the
time we just had 250 families displaced
from a housing complex and some kids are
going to have to go to Massachusetts if
kids that move four times in one year
these are American kids so understanding
that this is a really a universal
problem where we can speak to more local
agencies more friendly agencies might be
helpful to move this forward because
they're actually a lot of volunteers in
the mental health and education advocacy
that maybe your arms and legs locally
Angie did you want to respond late I'm
sorry because we are thank you for your
question we're running out of time and
maybe that's a good segue for really the
purpose of this and is again to get
recommendations so I know we have only a
few minutes but if from each one of you
how can we move this forward what what
from your vantage point should yell
engage in let's say in the short term
plan for now to sort of kick off a more
sustainable strategy for for supporting
partnership so if we could just walk out
of this room with some light and that I
think our goal has been accomplished
after we've spent time talking about
challenges so very very briefly I think
that you know the whole sensitivity
towards the refugee crisis it didn't
come from a government leader it didn't
even come from an NGO leader it came
from the power of message
it came from public opinion so I think
that events like this that raise
awareness and as Chris said to sustain
that interest us saying that because the
problems aren't going to go away
tomorrow it's going to be here for a
while and even if this problem goes away
there's going to be another problem that
comes up you know believe me so how do
we maintain this interest and awareness
and ownership I think is one thing the
second thing would be is that you know
we have tons and tons of evidence on
what works we think but we never seem to
use it we go back into the same
situation we try to recreate the will so
something that Yale could do I think as
risa at the end race and academic
community use this as an opportunity to
really monitor and gather information on
what is working in these in the
interventions and maybe what is not
working so that next time around the
crisis comes around and as I said
believe me it will then we know much
more quickly what to do thank you we
need to devote specific attention to the
health care needs of children refugee
resettlement agencies have to have the
resources to have someone dedicated to
the health care needs of refugees on
staff the same for education we must
have the resources and the support to
have at least one person devoted to
meeting the educational needs of
refugees I've done the math it's about
three hundred dollars per child per year
to sustain those services in the 350
refugee resettlement agencies across the
country that comes to only 12 million
dollars total so any of you know Bill
Gates or anyone in that category see me
afterwards
I think Yale is a collection of
brilliant minds so if we could put them
all together to come up with generating
what my colleagues have been saying
actionable evidence we we know what
works but often we can it there's a
difficulty in translation from the
published research to how we can
actually use it in the field and I think
some of the brilliant minds in this room
and your friends and colleagues can help
think through how we can actually
translate that in real time in practical
ways specifically we need better child
protection assessments that can look at
the sensitive issues for young children
UNICEF has done a great job in
developing interagency tools which we
use but there's still a long way to go
and I think that we can integrate that
with ICT we could find new innovative
ways to deploy these more effectively
and yeah several other initiatives I
think this kind of advocacy is really
important I don't want us to forget that
the crisis in the Middle East is
enormous and scale and scope but there
we work in 40 countries around the world
there are refugee crises that are
happening all the time that don't get
the same amount of media attention often
because there are places that are a
little bit less interesting perhaps to
the American public and so let's not
focus all of our attention only on this
one crisis let's think more broadly
about the geopolitics of refugees and
how we can be more effective now I fully
support what did you say and I think
it's an opportunity to use this to draw
attention to the broader crises around
the world definitely if anything changes
it benefit programming and policy work
more broadly if this spear point helps
us to move forward because of time
constraints let me just list the three
things i have on my mind for
recommendations one of course is the
research that data evidence base and
knowledge management don't just collect
the information and the knowledge but
use it to incite and
advocacy initiatives and to move a
broader coalition of people to support
initiatives in the field and also make
this a part of an ongoing dialogue in
the university second is I'm just
appalled and subtitle surprised by how
little people who are in leadership
positions making decisions that lead to
destruction of life and probably know
about the consequences of their action I
think that to a certain extent
leadership training and making sure that
our leaders have the level of
sophistication to see and connect the
dots across the political spectrum to
social and environmental aspects of what
they do it what the committee to do is
absolutely important and year has the
name recognition has the clout to be
able to bring about change in leadership
training that is directed specifically
at leaders that are part of conflict
that generate traffic and that map that
are managing conflict today it is not
too far-fetched for Yale to reach out to
commanders of peacekeeping operations
and commanders in the Chiefs of Staff of
several countries and have them spend
some time working with your people here
and lastly I think you have the best
institution around here to put together
standard operating procedures from the
evidence base that you collect that
would allow us to codify and be able to
deploy the tools and instruments that we
need to be able to work harmoniously
across different agencies and country
contests so I'm thinking when we say
best interest assessments what do we
mean does everybody have the same
definition and are we talking about data
that we can share across across
agencies so these are the three areas
that I think that you bring a lot of
value addition to what's being done in
the field I don't want to repeat what's
already been said I agree with the
previous speakers have said last week
Somali of again the 196 country to
ratify the Convention on the Rights of
the Child there's only one country left
to ratify that convention that's the
United States of America the only
country in the world who has not
ratified the convention the rights of
the child so why don't we start a
campaign why this is what the university
student should do this is what civil
society should do and this will address
not just the problems of refugee
children but also children in the US or
getting shot every day unsafe
environments at school I can go on and
on and on so that's I think in addition
to everything that you've said I mean us
is the only country that has not signed
this convention so let's perhaps that
would be a good place to start as a call
for action thank you thank you
we are just getting started how sad that
we met that but I feel less discouraged
than I often do after these
conversations because the
recommendations that you have given us
and the charge that you given to the
University with its resources and with
its remarkable assets and I hope
everyone here feels the burden of that
obligation and the opportunity I want to
finish asking because there isn't there
is an initiative that has begun here at
the University that starts very early in
this process to think differently about
children's experience and their appetite
for peace and how we can possibly
exploit it rather than extinguish it and
gee do you want to say something about
the early childhood peace building yes
for those of you who are not here at the
beginning our group at the Yale child
study center is engaged along with
UNICEF bachelor and other partners in a
global initiative to really shift the
paradigm of peace building towards
social investment in particular early
childhood again we believe that as we've
all been saying peace starts sustainable
peace starts in our children and their
families the consortium again is
emerging but a lot of exciting things
are happening and Yale is in the middle
of those conversations and we're talking
un level government level as well as
grass root level and work a lot around
knowledge transfer knowledge translation
knowledge brokering it's something that
is fairly nascent but that we really
need our yell community to rally around
and we are generating communication
platforms and strategies around so that
might be a venue or a mechanism for us
to sort of work together towards this
along with synergies that are starting
today so just very quickly you know
following this panel event a few of us
that have been convened and are ready to
discuss this are hoping to sort of
digest what has been said today talk to
the relevant sort of mechanisms here at
Yale to see how we can get something
either more formal or more structured
around this and we would like to
communicate that with you all we were
again
we're going to use our virtual
communication strategies are media who
are supporting us to make sure that you
stay engaged and the weekend in the most
coordinated and well-informed fashion
can move forward so again this is the
beginning thank you for being here and
please stay in touch in the days to come